good morning John thank you for your
lovely yesterday video today I want to
talk to you about a really weird reason
why it is worse for conservation to have
a Republican in the White House than to
have somebody from the Democratic Party
might think hey that's obvious
Republicans hate the environment not
really as more complicated than that it
turns out let's be honest both parties
like resource extraction it keeps energy
prices low and it makes us less
dependent on other countries resident
Obama did a great job of keeping gas and
energy prices low by having a whole lot
of fracking happen in America there are
a lot of reasons why conservative people
in the US are totally into land
conservation specifically they like to
use that for hunting and fishing and
recreation of various kinds but unless
your dad was the Florida State Director
of the Nature Conservancy which our dad
was you probably don't know about this
law that's very obscure and really
amazing and popular it's called the
pittman-robertson Act named after the
two senators who thought it up it was
signed into law in 1937 by FDR the idea
was one of the things that makes America
really interesting is that we have a lot
of open space in a way that the places
where a lot of Americans came from
Europe did not America is growing fast
land values are going up wildlife
management is all over the place so the
idea is we're gonna take existing
revenue from attacks on guns and bullets
and put that toward managing wildlife
and conserving land and in 1937 the main
reason people bought guns and ammo was
to hunt so basically you're just taxing
hunters specifically by taxing guns and
saying we're gonna use this to do stuff
that you want us to do to protect the
land so that there's still places for
people to recreate and shoot stuff and
also so that hunting won't become what
it mostly was in England which was a
rich person sport to keep it accessible
to more people nowadays guns and ammo
are bought for a wider variety of
reasons hunting still for sure
interestingly one of the biggest reasons
people buy guns and ammo is out of fear
that they will soon not be able to buy
certain types of guns or guns and
ammunition at all and does any good
marketing person will tell you the idea
that something is available for a
limited time only is really great at
motivating people to buy stuff now which
is why during Obama's eight years in
office pittman-robertson revenue went
from three hundred and ten million
dollars to a peak of over eight hundred
million dollars and suddenly states had
three times more money for their
conservation and wildlife biology
programs than they used to have and they
had
even had a hard time spending all of it
a lot of it went to local and national
land Trust's to acquire new land and of
course that land has to be like open to
hunters but it's also not open to
development and interestingly as the
pittman-robertson revenue has increased
the number of licensed hunters is going
doubts just not as popular a hobby as it
once was
so pittman-robertson is protecting
wildlife that's getting hunted less and
less and nobody doesn't like that though
people who buy guns even if they don't
hunt are proud and happy to support
hunters and people who might be in favor
of more gun regulations in America like
me also are probably more or less happy
that more land is getting conserved to
be clear if you want to support
conservation the best thing to do is to
donate to a local land trust rather than
buy OBO and Joe bullets but I find it
fascinating that a surge in the purchase
of firearms and ammunition inspired by a
fear that those things are gonna get
taken away from you by person who was in
the White House at that moment Julie did
amazing things for a wildlife
conservation over the last eight years
it's just weird
Johnny recently sent me a text it said I
forgot until just now that you are the
CEO of a board game company you are
hilarious and amazing I mean I wouldn't
I don't know that I'm the CEO I've just
helping make it work with dftba games
has a new fun weird silly party game
it's called Ralph you can watch a video
of me playing it or check it out on
Kickstarter will be kick-starting for
the next 24 days or so we've already
reached our goal so we are making the
game John I know that you can't come to
VidCon Australia but I will be there if
you're near enough to Melbourne or in
Melbourne I have a coupon code for yet
just use the coupon code Hey looking
forward to seeing all the people who can
come to VidCon Australia John I will see
you on Tuesday blood sweat and tacos the
Backstreet banjee banjo